ROGER MARTINEZ: It is week five
of "Google Cloud Next OnAir,"
and this week, we're
focusing on data analytics.
I'm Roger Martinez, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud,"
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week five is all
about data analytics,
meaning we want to help you
make the most of your data
by helping you efficiently
store and get insights from it.
We've got sessions on everything
from storing and streaming
your data to empowering it
with real time AI, BigQuery
ML, and more.
It's always exciting to hear
real world examples of how
people build on Google Cloud.
Don't Sweat The Big Stuff
is a perfect example.
Geotab talks about how
they use BigQuery and lots
of other tools to enable their
data science scene to analyze
petabytes of data.
The key here is to let them
focus on the data and models
while letting Google's
infrastructure
handle all the heavy lifting.
Now, I love to stay
on top of new updates
that make Google Cloud
tools easier to use.
So my pick for the week
is awesome new features
to help you manage BigQuery.
There's lots of great
ways in the Cloud
to help you wrangle your
data, but BigQuery really
shines this week.
This talk is perfect for
newcomers and power users
alike with practical ways to
get your head around pricing,
administration, and monitoring.
To round out the week,
make sure to check out
the cool demos that show what
data analytics can help you do.
This week features
some great videos
and a cool interactive demo
that visualizes MLB pitcher
data in a 3D environment.
Whether you're a sports fan,
a statistics expert, or just
like playing around
with interactive demos,
be sure to take a look.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or
tweet us using the hashtag
#GoogleCloudNext.
We'll see you in the Cloud.